Bruder lebst du noch
[Musik]
ich sehe aus als hätte ich mich mit
jedem Mitarbeiter hier einmal Fett
geprügelt aber nein es ist einfach wohl
anscheinend Allergie bevor ich zur Infos
ist übrigens 7:18 Uhr an unserem zweiten
Tag auf der AIDA gestern haben wir
einfach absolut gar nichts gefilmt und
falls ihr jetzt fragen sollte mensch
Luca warum bist du denn so früh wach ist
nicht meine Idee gewesen
wir müssen drehen eigentlich kann man
dann jetzt schon mal ein paar Liegen
reservieren
[Musik]
mein Auge ist auf jeden Fall
übertriebens angeschwollen ich muss das
Tag 1 Tag Auskühlen ich weiß auch
ehrlich gesagt nicht ob kühlen da die
besten Medizin ist gerade ne ich weiß
nicht bei was nutzt man Wärme bei was
weil morgen
wir drehen heute auf jeden Fall in
unserem sparbereich und äh
keine Ahnung
[Musik]
ich bin am Arbeiten
also
jetzt sehen sie einen Dulli der zum
ersten Mal ein Wasserbett betritt
wir fahren oder bin ich besoffen noch
Josef es reicht du brauchst nicht mehr
Film
der denkt manchmal
einfach mal gönnen
[Musik]
mitgebracht
die gibt es im Auge Meister beschissen
meine lieben Freunde wir haben
tatsächlich das erste Mal die AIDAstella
verlassen um unseren ersten warte
zum allerersten Mal die AIDAstella
verlassen um die erste Stadt auf unserem
Trip
ich einfach eine Kirche ein wir befinden
uns gerade in Malaga
ist echt groß ne jeden Fall gehen wir
jetzt was essen wir gehen shoppen wir
gehen chillen wir gehen grillen wir
gehen einen Kasten Pillen und ich muss
pinkeln typisch deutsch habe ich mich
auch übrigens schick gemacht hier für
die Stadt wird schneller ein bisschen
wie heißen Spanier ohne Auto
[Musik]
wir sind jetzt hier gerade bei der Burg
von Malaga angekommen meine lieben
Freunde AK einfach ein Mauer Klotz
ich mein Battle flip
sagen sie zu dem Bingo
habe es leider verpasst
[Musik]
wir gehen jetzt nach Cadiz meine lieben
Freunde das ist die älteste Stadt Süd
Europas habe ich irgendwo gehört weiß
nicht ob das stimmt aber wir gehen auf
jeden Fall hin wir stehen hier gerade
vor dem Schloss von Cardis eine
wunderschöne Ort schaut euch mal an
es ist halt for real einfach ein Schloss
mega korrekt übrigens das Sandra auch
mitgekommen ist in die Stadt
gucken
da die Kamera tatsächlich nach dieser
Szene einfach kaputt gegangen ist
wahrscheinlich weil Josef einfach so
viel gefilmt hat werde ich euch den Rest
der eiderreise jetzt einfach anhand von
insta Stories ein bisschen erläutern
denn nachdem wir in der Stadt waren
haben wir ein bisschen im Gym trainiert
und auch Hula Hoop gemacht gegen eine
Trainerin dort vor Ort und da wir dann
schon in unserem Sportfilm waren haben
wir dann gesagt das war noch eine Runde
Fußball spielen die haben nämlich
einfach im Fußballplatz auf dem Deck
das mit dem Film hat allerdings nicht
ganz so gut funktioniert
perfekt als ich dann jedoch zurück auf
dem Zimmer war wollte ich einfach nur
ein geiles Video von mir aufnehmen ich
zeige es mal kurz
Roomservice kam rein hat mich dann
erstmal gefragt oh what you doing
Youtube
for YouTube und nicht das ist für meine
Mutter
oberkörperfrei auf jeden Fall habe ich
das so meine insta Story gepostet und
auf einmal eine Stunde später was sehe
ich verfolgt mir
ich bin nicht so verzweifelt Single
gerade eine Beziehung hinter mir ich
suche jetzt nicht direkt schon wieder
hier irgendwer nächstes parsche auf
jeden Fall sind wir dann jedoch abends
noch auf so eine silent Party gegangen
dass man irgendwie so Kopfhörer auf
[Musik]
ich bin ganz ehrlich ich fand das dann
tatsächlich auch gar nicht mal so
schlecht in die Kiste Olivia
lalalalalalalalala Olivia am nächsten
Tag sind wir dann auf jeden Fall in
Lissabon angekommen
was einfach gefühlt San Francisco auf
wish ist
[Musik]
ich habe dann auch tatsächlich ein paar
Leute von euch aus der Luke schon
Portugal getroffen
und dann haben wir uns dazu entschlossen
eine hop-on-hop auf Bustour zu machen
übelstahlmann hier Sandra habe ich den
mitgebracht für Privatkonsum
und wenn ihr nach Lissabon fliegt kann
ich euch wirklich nur empfehlen nicht
E-Scooter ausleihen denn das nur
Pflastersteine und alles geht bergauf
und übelstahl bergab
[Musik]
doch dann haben wir in der Innenstadt so
ein Maler gesehen der gesagt hat dass
der Touristen zeichnet wir lassen uns ja
gerade in der lissabona Innenstadt malen
okay Leute no joke die stehen jetzt hier
alle drumherum aus dem fremde Menschen
und gucken einfach drauf und lachen
und ich zeige euch jetzt mal meine
Reaktion auf das Endergebnis
hier sehen Sie eine wunderschöne
karikaturistische Zeichnung von einem
wunderschönen Menschen und einer Frau
mit einem viel zu großen Doppelkinn doch
dann sind wir auch einfach nur noch
schlafen gegangen und am nächsten Tag
dann zum Flughafen wo wir dann im
Flieger erstmal noch zwei Stunden
mussten weil die Franzosen irgendwie
gestreikt haben und wir deswegen in
französischen Luft rum nicht überfliegen
durften
wir haben uns die Zeit dann allerdings
mit UNO spielen totgeschlagen und damit
meine ich nicht normales UNO sondern mit
50 Karten auf der Hand dreimal durch die
Raten Match schlussendlich gewonnen hat
doch dann waren wir endlich am Fliegen
und sind dann schlussendlich auch in
Deutschland angekommen
das war es von der AIDA-Reise wir sehen
uns die Tage wieder einen neuen Video
tschüss